hi folks i'm steven crowder and tis the
season to watch out for that cliff
[Music]
first question yes what is the fiscal
cliff I don't know ok I actually
remember half of any of I don't know no
idea at all what do you mean by that I
admit I don't know too much about it
it's a really scary prospect Democrats
or Republicans who do you think would
have the better ideas in the fiscal
cliff how to deal with it I would say I
lean more towards Democrats Democrat I
would probably lean more Democrat I'm
probably a pretty strong Democrat what
about this idea of closing loopholes in
the tax system I think that's a good
idea I think it's a good thing I think
that's super important I think that
people should pay in their fair share of
taxes yeah I do I think it's needed yeah
that makes sense
when do you think we should raise taxes
if at all when they have at least know
it now if I would say it should start
anything over a million the whole
household makes 250,000 should they be
taxed like the richest people in the
country
you're not saying up super wealthy no no
so you would disagree with raising taxes
on families on the making 250 yeah
[Music]
what about the idea of just raising the
debt ceiling that ID probably a poor
decision that's not solving a problem is
making it larger oh my what you know
what that makes you if you were a
Republican a Republican you just thumbs
no you get any back no racism
[Applause]
[Music]
and